ja wir menschen haben schon ein sehr
seltsames verhältnis zu den tieren
wir lieben die einen und verschlingen
die anderen und ich vermute mal die
wenigsten von ihnen die fleisch essen
können mit ansehen wie ein tier
geschlachtet wird
warum also diese widersprüche müssen wir
unseren umgang mit den tieren vielleicht
von grund auf überdenken
darüber spreche ich heute mit dem wohl
populärsten philosophen deutschlands mit
richard david precht für ihn gibt es
zwei kategorien von tieren die eine
glaubt dass es zwei kategorien von
tieren gibt und die andere hat darunter
zu leiden
herzlich willkommen gerne ja halb rechts
waren sie eigentlich schon mal in einem
schlachthof
ich bin einmal in meinem leben in einem
schlachthof gewesen das war 1996 bei den
recherchen für das buch was ich damals
war das verhältnis von mensch und tier
geschrieben habe und da habe ich mir
auch einige massentierhaltungsbetrieb
angeschaut und auch legebatterie
was hat das alles gelöst das hat
eigentlich bestätigt was man vorher aus
filmen schon kannte und wusste
insofern war es keine völlig neue
erfahrung weil gerade zu dem zeitpunkt
90er jahren gab es sehr sehr viele
dokumentationen darüber und die haben
vor allen dingen erst mal was ausgelöst
ich denke hoch dass er etwas das man in
bilder nicht hat na ja das stimmt ja da
so hochkommt sicherheit noch ganz
intensiv dazu
und selbstverständlich das ist was
verstören dass wir jemand der das nicht
gewohnt ist und die auch nicht
abgestumpft ist für den es in einem
schlachthof zu sagen kein vergnügen das
kann man wohl sagen
trotzdem plädieren sie dafür dass
eigentlich alle menschen das einmal im
leben tun sollten etwa in der schule
oder zum beispiel ja also ich bin mir
natürlich dessen bewusst dass das keine
realistische forderung ist aber ich
möchte die leute zumindest zum
nachdenken darüber anregen also ich
glaube wenn man sagen ja meiner
september achten klasse der schule eine
biologie unterricht oder in
sozialkundeunterricht eine expedition
macht und schlachthöfe besichtigt dann
würde wahrscheinlich die hälfte der
schüler anschließend kein fleisch mehr
essen
wir können jetzt hier keine schlachthof
besichtigung machen aber wir können
bilder zeigen videoausschnitt und das
werden wir tun
gleich am anfang der sendung damit wir
sehen was da nicht tagtäglich geschieht
und für sie liebe zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer wenn sie sensibel sind möchte
sie waren sind ein paar bilder dabei die
nicht so appetitlich sind ein
schlachthaus im basellandschaftlichen
gelterkinden hierher bringt der bauer
seine tiere noch selber die anfahrtswege
sind uns die tiere stammen alle aus
artgerechter haltung
hintergrund ist die taktik klub tampa
bay auf der stelle lagert was hab ich
doch eben hier ist die eine arbeit wie
als das mussten wir respektvoll ordnung
wie es ist und das heißt der größte
respekt und anstand zu dienen und somit
ungefährlich
mit dem bolzenschuss wird das tier
lediglich betreuung
danach haben die metzger 20 bis 30
sekunden zeit das tier mit einem schnitt
durch die kehle ausbluten zu lassen und
honig wohnt ist und dank in etwas große
run blick ja und ob irgendwo auf die
ungarn
und wenn wir ihnen auch im raum der
sauna
warum bin ich keine 76 oder
verbandstrainer
an diesem morgen werden hier in diesem
familienbetrieb 25 schweine geschlachtet
ihnen sind drei kälber oder ein rind
vorangegangen pro jahr werden in der
schweiz laut probiert 64 millionen tiere
geschlachtet
die betreibung der schweine erfolgt mit
der elektro zange nach dem ausbluten
werden sie geprüft und den tag
der metzgermeister spricht von respekt
gegenüber den tieren und einer
schmerzlosen tötung ist denn das respekt
vor dem was da passiert na ja also ich
glaube menschen sind unglaublich begabt
darin das was sie tun mit moralischen
rechtfertigungen zu versehen
weil man sich wahrscheinlich sonst nicht
gut fühlt und so wird er sich einreden
dass das respektvoll ist was wir da
gerade gesehen haben aber ich denke der
größte teil der zuschauer wird diesen
respekt nicht wahrnehmen
aber das tier wird schon richtig betäubt
dann durch diesen bolzenschuss oder bei
einem schwein durch diese elektro zange
die spüren dann nichts mehr von der nähe
aber also das interessante war ja dass
in dem film gesagt wurde die tiere sind
deswegen irritiert war das ungewohnt
umgebung ist es ist natürlich nicht
falsch aber ist nicht das einzige tiere
sind schon sehr sensibel die kriegen
schon mit dass das ein ort des todes es
sie haben sehr feinen geruchssinn ja die
können ihre toten artgenossen das blut
und so weiter riechen und wittern die
marken in dem moment dass hier etwas
ganz ganz furchtbares passiert das etwas
was sie mit ihrem verstand vielleicht
nicht greifen können aber etwas was sie
ganz tiefe befinden können sie das
belegen sieht man das am verhalten der
tiere haben sie gesehen wie die ohren
von dem schwein gezittert haben wie das
geguckt hat ja das ist ja nicht so dass
alltäglich so van der weck wasser
passiert sondern ich will sie nicht nur
wegen des umgebungs wechsels verstört es
ist ja völlig klar ich meine viele
dieser tiere schweine zum beispiel
orientieren sich vor allen dingen durch
den beruf sind dh deren groß wenn es
sehr viel sensibler als ihre sehkraft
und natürlich bekommen die über den
geruchssinn völlig mit was da abläuft
also ohne ist vielleicht zu begreifen
aber natürlich haben die panik sie haben
jetzt hier beispiele gesehen von
schweini nicht kriegen also was ich im
schlachthof gesehen habe waren sehr sehr
laut schreiende das wäre ein klares
indiz dafür wie kindes schweine die
völlig verstört waren als sie vom
transport herunterkamen und so weiter
gibt es ein tierfreundlich arten der der
tötung oder der schlachtung zum beispiel
beide schlachtung ja also ich in letzter
zeit gibt es ja die neue theorie wie
wär's denn eigentlich wenn wir die tiere
einfach schön auf der wiese halten
würden und wie in jäger die einfach vom
hoch und runter verschießen und gut
ist's ja also möglicherweise ist das
eine artgerechte reform der tötung
obwohl es uns im ersten augenblick sehr
verstörend er schon frauen für die tiere
die ersten herum stehen dann
wahrscheinlich müssen wir das genauso
mit ansehen was müsste ich ja die tiere
erstmal in ein einzelgänger gemacht wo
ich sie erschießen jemand auch wendet
und dreht ja man kommt überhaupt nicht
daraus dass man das gefühl hat das was
wir hier tun ist nicht in ordnung
verdrängen wir dass diese realität also
der mensch der welt an die dinge zu
verdrängen wir denken ja auch nicht
jeden tag über unseren eigenen tod nach
wir denken nicht jeden tag darüber nach
wie viele menschen in den ländern der
sogenannten dritten welt sterben und auf
eine ähnliche art und weise sind wir
auch begabteren das was hinter den
kulissen was haben wir gerade für zahlen
wird 64 millionen fach- oder so allein
in der schweiz stattfindet einfach
möglichst nicht wahrzunehmen und die
meisten zuschauer werden jetzt diesen
film nicht gerne gesehen haben
aber sie werden in der lage sein dass
innerhalb kurzer zeit wieder zu
verdrängen und in ein zwei tagen
schmecken jetzt leben wir wir erleben in
der heutigen zeit oder seit einigen
jahren jahrzehnten vielleicht einen
trend hin zum zu vegetariern veganern
warum ist das eigentlich so
warum gerade erst ist eine frage der
sensibilisierung also aller moralischer
fortschritt in der gesellschaft ist
abhängig davon wie sensibel eine
gesellschaft ist und wenn man jetzt eine
lange linie zieht verhältnis zwischen
mensch und tier dann kann man ablesen
dass in sehr viel früheren kulturen so
in den wild beuter gesellschaften haben
wir das er heute noch die menschen sehr
respektvoll mit tieren umgegangen sind
das heißt sie haben sich schon gejagt
aber dann haben sie sich bei den göttern
entschuldigt dafür dass sie sie töten
müssen und tiere waren ein teil mitten
der mitwelt
also waren spiritualität götter waren
tiergestalt ich wir sehen das ja noch
bei den alten ägyptern ein großer teil
der götter ist hier gestaltet und ihr
kürzlich und diese bewandtnis
zusammenhang in die menschen sich mit
tieren vor
angefühlt haben gemeinsam der natur
ausgeliefert gemeinsam himmlischen
mächten ausgeliefert der wird in dem
moment zerstört als der mensch anfängt
systematisch ackerbau und viehzucht zu
betreiben also durch die neolithische
revolution die landwirtschaft beendet
das spirituelle verhältnis zum tier und
dann haben wir das lange diese
agrargesellschaft gehabt also seit der
jungsteinzeit bei uns und in diesen
gesellschaften ist das verhältnis zum
tier entfremdet und in den modernen
großstädten haben wir nichts mehr mit
diesem landwirtschaftlichen leben zu tun
dass die entfremdeten uns jetzt von der
entfremdung und gewinnen quasi über den
zweiten bildungsweg ein sensibles
verhältnis zu tieren wieder zurück das
ist das was ich im augenblick in vielen
ländern der westlichen welt ereignet
also total entfremdung gleichzeitig so
sensibel der noch über die totale
enthält entsteht sozusagen neu die
sensibilität und wenn ich sie jetzt
frage sie haben dieses buch geschrieben
tiere denken vor 20 jahren haben sie das
erste tier rechts buch geschrieben hat
die ethik buch warum müssen wir uns mit
diesem thema befassten einmal
philosophen da ich meine es gibt ja
genug elend und andere treten der primär
auf der welt migration armut elend
also erstmal gibt es natürlich auch ein
zusammenhang also es gibt zwei arten die
frage zu beantworten die eine ist zu
sagen es geht in der ethik nicht immer
darum das wichtigste zu tun
das ist eine ganz ganz wichtige einsicht
das wichtigste also wenn alle menschen
immer sagen würden was ist denn
eigentlich in moralischer hinsicht das
größte problem der menschheit ja wir
müssten sich alle ausnahmslos für
dieselbe sache engagieren und für alle
anderen sachen würde sich keiner mehr
engagieren ja das wäre ein ganz
eigenartiges bild also alle würden gegen
den hunger in der welt oder alle würden
gegen den klimawandel und alles andere
würde sein gelassen
da würde man sich jetzt nicht mehr darum
kümmert keinen artenschutz später war es
halt genau war das nicht so wichtig ist
das ist natürlich eine seltsame
vorstellung von mauer das zweite ist
sehr viel elend in der dritten welt
hängt tatsächlich unmittelbar mit der
tierhaltung zusammen und sehr viel elend
für die gesamte menschheit hängt damit
zusammen 60 prozent der böden werden für
tierfutter genutzt der
landwirtschaftlichen anbaufläche und das
ist unvorstellbar viel land was
natürlich sonst zur verfügung stünde zum
menschlichen getreideanbau zum beispiel
oder leben anderen lebens wird gemüse an
das wird aber einzig und allein genutzt
also nordrhein westfalen jetzt jede
zweite fläche ist ein maisfeld für die
massentierhaltung
das ist also alles was was hat nicht
warnt menschen zugute kommt sondern nur
über den umweg der tierhaltung menschen
und auch nur bestimmte menschen das
zweite ist die ökologische katastrophe
also wir alle wissen von den methan
ausscheidung der in dagegen ganz
gewaltiger klimakiller sind dann
natürlich auch die ganzen ammoniak
nitrat nitrit vergiftung der böden das
geht von da aus ins grundwasser das geht
über die flüsse in die meere das
verseucht die meere von allen
ökologischen bedrohungen die wir heute
haben in der welt also einschließlich im
gefängnis gefahren industrial- ismus
unseres verkehrs ist die landwirtschaft
insbesondere die tierhaltung der
schlimmste fehler überhaupt bauen sind
ja wir haben hier eine grafik die das
zeigt was eigentlich ein kilogramm
rindfleisch was das alles braucht es
wirklich eindrücklich wie viel wasser da
gebracht werden also es ist also nicht
nur aus ethischen also eben auch aus
ökologischer perspektive so dass wir
diese form von massentierhaltung nicht
mehr weiter betreiben dürfen klar es
gibt natürlich auch unterschiede zum
beispiel der schweiz muss man weniger
stark bewässern das muss man vielleicht
noch sagen das ist natürlich ein
globaler durchschnitt und ist die frage
kann man das irgendwie ändern zum
beispiel indem man den den rindern
futter gibt wo sie dann nicht so viel
wissen und nicht so viel methan raus
lassen zum beispiel ich weiß nicht
vielleicht gibt es die eine oder andere
ja aber ich glaube deshalb wird sich
dabei um schönheitsoperationen an einem
krebskranken patienten ja also das große
problem besteht in dieser
massentierhaltung und wir können durch
kleine chirurgische eingriffe das
problem nicht wirklich lösen
das wird wahrscheinlich nur noch größer
wenn jetzt china und indien usw ja wir
haben riesige wachstumsmärkte
die waadtländer die sie angesprochen
haben china insbesondere es gibt heute
200 millionen chinesen die die
möglichkeit haben fleisch zu essen die
vorher die möglichkeit zugute überhaupt
nicht hatten also die ganz ganz arme
reisbauern waren und für die fleisch
ganz ganz selten war und die die städte
drängen und dort als industriearbeiter
als wanderarbeiter leben und dann auch
mittlerweile in der lage sind ist eben
fleischliche nahrung zu kaufen und
deswegen weltweit wächst die nachfrage
nach fleisch mehr und mehr
also wir müssen einfach aus ökologischen
gründen weniger fleisch essen sonst
bräuchten wir einfach mehr werden aber
es nützt gar nichts wenn die menschen
beispielsweise in deutschland sagen wir
essen kein fleisch mehr weil die
deutschen landwirtschaftlichen intensiv
alter wie sie sich selber nennen also
die massen tierhalter ja nicht für den
deutschen markt produzieren sondern
mittlerweile für einen weltmarkt
produzieren
mit der folge dass ein deutscher bauer
an einem schwein was er vom ferkel an
groß die bis zum erwachsenen schwein
wenn er sehr viel glück hat sechs euro
verdient wenn er sich hat vielleicht nur
zwei denn all diese dinge sind ja auch
noch gegenstand von spekulationen an der
börse also warentermingeschäfte ich
meine dieses ökologische problem das ist
das eine und das andere über das möchten
jetzt ein bisschen sprechen das ist das
thema ethische problem oder das tierwohl
und da gibt's ja in der schweiz wie in
vielen ländern ein tierschutzgesetz und
ich möchte mal vorlesen was dadurch
entsteht der mit tieren umgeht hat
erstens ihren bedürfnissen invest
möglicherweise rechnung zu tragen und
zweitens so weit ist der
verwendungszweck zuletzt für ihr
wohlergehen zu sorgen
niemand darf ungerechtfertigt einem tier
schmerzen leiden oder schäden zufügen es
in angst versetzen oder in anderer weise
seine würde missachten und im deutschen
tierschutzgesetz steht niemand darf
einem tier ohne vernünftigen grund
schmerzen leiden schäden zu sehen
reicht denn das eigentlich nicht was da
drin steht ja im prinzip würde das
reichen
aber es ist zu keinem zeitpunkt ernst
gemeint gewesen also tierschutzgesetze
sind entstanden gegen unnötige
tierquälerei
das ist ihre historische wurzeln und der
vernünftige grund aus denen man tiere
nun leiden und schäden zufügen darf ist
jeder erdenkliche ökonomisch sinnvolle
grund also menschen tragen gerne
pelzmäntel deswegen ist es legitim
märz zu vergasen dass dieses bedürfnis
ist ein fernes ist es das ist in der
auslegung des tierschutzgesetzes dass er
tatsächlich ein tier nutzungs gesetzes
ist es ein vernünftiger grund ja das ist
natürlich nicht etwas wurde mehr sagen
als philosophen vernünftig sagen würden
sondern vernünftig ist ein synonym für
ökonomische gründe
und es ist interessant wir haben ja so
viel kosmetik eingeführt im schweizer
gesetz steht das wort würde im deutschen
auch 1986 ist auch die würde des tieres
ins tierschutzgesetz eingekauft bedeutet
ja da heißt es es geht darum die würde
des tieres als mitgeschöpf pietisten
wort aus dem 17 schweden 17 frühen
achtzehnten jahrhundert dass man da rein
gemacht man hat das ganze mit einem
goldenen mantel verbrämt der in einem
völligen widerspruch steht zu diesem
gesetz denn das tierschutzgesetz handelt
über die wenigen seiten aus denen es
versteht die ganze zeit vom
fachgerechten töten
ja und nicht von von der
sensibilisierung gegenüber dem team von
von was bei würde da denken wir ein an
liebe dann denken wir einige und vieles
andere mehr
diese dinge tauchen im tierschutzgesetz
gar nicht auf das ist ein kurzer text
über das töten
gibt es denn aus ihrer philosophischen
sicht vernünftige gründe ein tier
einzusperren und zu töten
also es hat ja in der geschichte der
menschheit viele kulturen gegeben die
ohne den verzehr von fleisch nicht
hätten existieren können sehr lange galt
das für die inuits in alaska zum
beispiel das hat auch für die
neandertaler gegolten
als sie in regionen vordringen in dem im
winter keine fetten pflanzen wuchsen von
denen sie sich ernähren konnten und die
sie auch nicht einlegen konnten also
unsicher ist noch kein sauerkraut machen
und das würde ich sagen also wenn es ums
überleben geht dann ist das töten eines
tieres auch aus meiner sicht ein
vernünftiger grund dann sind wir uns
allerdings einig dass in unseren
gesellschaften des nirgends worum es
überleben diesbezüglich mehr geht also
wir brauchen kein fleisch
nein das weiß jeder dass der mensch kein
fleisch braucht man kann lange darüber
streiten ob es wirklich gesund es sich
vegan zu ernähren da bin ich auch kein
experte aber vegetarier zu sein es
medizinisch unbedenklich es ist sogar
unterm strich gesünder
wie ist es mit labour es gibt da diese
bio labels oder dem erzieher oder natur
wie von so weiter in der schweiz
erinnert dass die sache sowohl aus
ökologischer als theoretischer ebene
also ich finde natürlich ernst genommene
ökologische oder biologische sensible
tierhaltung natürlich sehr viel besser
als massentierhaltung
das ist für mich nicht das gleiche also
ob das ist ihr zeit seines lebens ein
halbwegs glückliches leben hatte oder ob
es ein gefecht auf weniger als einen
quadratmeter pro schwein in risiken
halten es mit einer großen tätowierung
ist nummer auf dem rücken und das
tageslicht nicht sieht das ist natürlich
nicht das gleiche also da würde ich auf
jeden fall eine abstufung machen
nichtsdestotrotz könnte ich mir eine
zukünftige gesellschaft vorstellen der
irgendwann die biobauern an dem gleichen
pranger stehen an dem jetzt die massen
tierhalter stehen nämlich dann wenn die
massentierhaltung abgeschafft
es gibt viele philosophien und
philosophen tierrechtler die sagen eben
diese unterscheidung ist eigentlich
irrelevant zwischen tieren die ein
bisschen besser gehalten werden als
andere sondern müssen dieses ganze diese
ganze nutzung von tieren abschaffen und
das ganze beginnt spätestens mit peter
singer 19 75 mit der befreiung der tiere
australische philosoph und natürlich
doch ist
mich interessiert bevor wir über das
sprechen noch die tradition in der
philosophiegeschichte das tier
rechtsdenken wo beginnt das eigentlich
was sind so die leitplanken also die
ganz frühen anfänge gehen tatsächlich
zurück bis in die aufklärungszeit es hat
im deutschen ein mainzer
philosophieprofessor gegeben den
eigentlich keiner kennt namens wilhelm
dittler er hat nicht nur ein buch über
logik geschrieben sondern auch ein buch
mit dem titel gerechtigkeit gegen tiere
und der wird zum ersten mal die
forderung aufgestellt ist ihre rechte
haben sollten im deutschsprachigen raum
noch etwas älter ist die tradition
mangel sächsischen raum wo aus der
politischen bewegung carlos ein
verändertes tier verhältnis entsteht und
das wird besonders stark mit den
crackern die quäker haben ein sensibles
verhältnis zum tier aufgrund einer
theologischen begründung
sie sagen durch die erbsünde ist das
ganze leben so mühsal plackerei geworden
also adams verfehlung hat das
menschliche leben schlecht gemacht so
wie es in der bibel stehen und die tiere
können ja gar nichts dafür aber der
paradiesgarten ist ja auch für die tiere
vorbei er hat sie sind also sozusagen
die unschuldig mitgefangenen der
menschlichen verfehlungen und deswegen
haben wir besonders sensibel und
vorsichtig mit ihnen umzugehen
gegen diese idee der krone der schöpfung
eigentlich oder die ja ja also ganz
erstaunlich also dass widerspricht
natürlich dem klassischen christlichen
weltbild man darf ja nicht vergessen
also eben mehr klassisch jüdischen
schöpfungsgeschichte wird dem sechstage
plan in dem gott die welt schafft wird
alles das was kreucht und fleucht für
den menschen gemacht dass ein tropisches
verständnis kein wunder denn ich meine
das stammt aus einer aus einer
gesellschaft die in sieben die ariden
gebieten gelebt haben also halb
wüstenbewohner und halbwüsten bewohner
haben ein ganz anderes verhältnis zu
tieren als etwa die ägypter den hütten
das alte ägypten serengeti also da gab
es elefanten nashörnern zahlreiche
antilopen und er gleich das können wir
alles in ruhe prüfen ja noch dem
flusspferde ja und die hatten ein
anderes verhältnis zur natur als in den
halbwüsten wo es ganz wenig die ehre
gibt und wo jedes tier der leopard und
die frauen so eigentlich nur eine
gefährdung der erde darstellen
und da ändert sich sozusagen durch die
veränderung der lebensumstände das
gleiche gilt für das alte griechenland
auf eine semi ariden region ändert sich
das ganze theologische verhältnis zum
tier
viele tiere rechnerin stützen sich ja
dann auf die eu gitarristen namentlich
auf den begründer auf jeremy bentham der
geschrieben hat
ja ja die tat ist ist sehr oft zitiert
ja ja das ist 17 89 die frage ist nicht
können sie die tiere der jacken oder
kann sie sprechen sondern können sie
leider aber bentheim hat selber keine
konsequenz daraus gezogen
also wenn sie den text dann auch weiter
lesen dann sehen sie dass er kein
problem damit hatte dass man tiere
gegessen hat deswegen ist das also die
frage ist zwar richtig gestellt aber
band em hat dann schon weiter gedacht
also und elitär ist gedacht na ja gut
also ist natürlich die tiere nicht schön
wenn wir sie halten und wenn wir sie
essen aber es ist natürlich auch gut
dass die leute fleisch essen ja und dann
hat er so abgewogen und da wäre ja so
viel leiden ist es
vielleicht nicht und eigentlich ist
unterm strich okay was halten sie denn
von diesem kriterium der
empfindungsfähigkeit das noch nicht sagt
tiere sind nicht so kluge wir haben eine
moral aber eigentlich spielt das doch
keine rolle wichtig ist dass sie
empfinden können dass ich schmerzen
haben ja also zunächst mal ist das ein
auf den ersten blick sehr überzeugendes
argument weil wir ja genauso umgehen
würden mit neugeborenen wir würden ja
sagen ein neugeborener hat kein allzu
komplexes bewusstsein also keine klare
zukunftsvorstellungen keine biografie er
ist nicht im gleichen maße bewusstseins
fähig wären erwachsener mensch warum
schützen wir neugeborene warum gehen wir
sensibel mit ihnen um weil wir sagen
natürlich sind die extrem
empfindungsfähigkeit würden auch sagen
weil sie erst zum teil verbunden sind
aber wir würden auch sagen weil sie
natürlich sensible und empfindung mäßig
gewesen sind und ich würde nicht sagen
was gehen kann ja nicht sprechen das hat
jetzt keinen hohen lebenswert das würden
wir niemals tun
aber die gleiche argumentation machen
wir gegenüber tiere und so gesehen kann
man sagen das war ein gewaltiger
fortschritt diesen leidens gedanken in
die die ethik diskussion einzubringen
was sicher nicht als erster gemacht hat
aber was er 1975 in sozusagen sehr
überzeugende art und weise in ein sehr
gut geschriebenes buch gepackt hat und
damit quasi die tierrechtsbewegung
begründet hat wenn man es ganz streng
nimmt hat das kriterium ein problem und
das problem es ich habe mit zynga die
gelegenheit gehabt sehr sehr lange schon
mal zu diskutieren und habe ihm das
damals auch gesagt also das problem ist
wir finden legebatterien falsch weil die
hühner in legebatterien definitiv leiden
also wollen wir sie abschaffen
was ist wenn ich gentechnisch
manipulierte hühner nehme ja oder den
gegen hühnern ein bestimmtes sie herum
gebe was dazu führt dass sie keine
schmerzen empfinden dann wäre ja in dem
moment wo ich das tier quasi
ethnologisch taub machen da das halten
von hühnern in legebatterien ok müsste
das okay sein wenn nur das kriterium der
empfindungsfähigkeit genau also
offensichtlich scheint das kriterium der
empfindungsfähigkeit nicht allein
auszureichen
aber wenn ich das richtig verstanden
habe gibt bei singe auch das kriterium
des interesses
was es ist ja ein präferenz und elitär
ist schaut auf die interessen der
betroffenen hätten dann so sieht ihre
keine interessen wenn sie keine
schmerzen haben sich ja doch noch was
essen die möchten daraus letztlich immer
die frage was ist mein interesse wenn
wenn ich sie jetzt heute nacht ja mit
einem schmerzlosen mittel im schlaf töte
dann haben sie ja in bayern ohne
bewusstsein in der nacht ja kann ich
sozusagen nicht ablesen dass sie ein
interesse daran haben weiterzuleben kein
bewusstes zumindest aber mindestens ist
kein bewusstes ja und dann könnte ich ja
das geld das sie hinterlassen einen
wohltätigen verein spenden und die frage
ist wenn sie jetzt unermesslich reich
wären hätte ich ja regelrecht die
verpflichtung dazu das zu tun weil ich
ein unglaubliches glück in die welt
setzen würde in dem moment wo ich das
tue das wäre peter singer sagen das
würde peter singer nicht sagen ich habe
diese frage konkret gestellt und er hat
dazu gesagt na ja es gibt ein argument
dagegen und dieses argument besteht
darin dass alle leute die viel geld
haben ja dann ihres lebens nicht mehr
sicher sein könnten
und wenn das so wäre würde das eine
gewaltige unruhe in die gesellschaft
bringen und das würde ja auch leiden
verursachen
das ist aber schon so ein bisschen so
ein trick gewesen es ist so ein bisschen
schon die schwachstelle der theorie dass
die leidensfähigkeit oder mutmaßliche
nicht aktuelle sondern zukünftige
präferenzen ein bisschen dünn sind um
auf dem die tierrechtsbewegung allein
mit einer guten theorie zu unterfüttern
ich meine das ist das eine problem das
andere haben sie schon erwähnt mit den
neugeborenen oder schwerstbehinderten ja
dass man da natürlich auch nicht
wirklich begründen kann warum die ein
lebensrecht haben also ganz richtig also
wenn man jetzt sagt das ist die
bewusstseins fähigkeit oder die
leidensfähigkeit
dann muss wenn ein haus brennt und die
mutter hat die gelegenheit ein
schäferhund zu retten oder ihr
neugeborenes müsste die mutter den
schäferhund retten weil der schäferhund
mutmaßlich über das komplexere
bewusstsein verfügt als er neu geboren
ist und singer sagt darauf das stimmt
aber ich verstehe jede mutter die ihr
kind rettet weil mütter haben ja so ein
instinkt und jetzt taucht plötzlich der
instinkt auf von dem war froh überhaupt
nicht die rede
und das ging die anzahl um gerechtigkeit
was muss ich unter dem gesichtspunkt der
gerechtigkeit machen wer mehr
bewusstsein hat hat ein höheres
lebensrecht als jemand der weniger
bewusst
der leidensfähige ist ja ist mehr zu
schützen als jemand der weniger
leidensfähig ist und jetzt kommt er
plötzlich mit dem instinkt um die ecken
sie hat dann frage ich mich immer darum
bauen wir den instinkt nicht von
vornherein in die theorie ein ja und
benutzen ihn nicht nur als hintertür
also menschen haben ein anderes
verhältnis im regelfall zu menschen als
zu tieren
das ist ein kompliziertes feld weil es
gibt menschen die leben ihrem
schäferhund weit mehr als irgendein
asylant der in die schweiz möchte das
weiß ich und trotzdem haben wir das
gefühl als menschen in einem
menschlichen bewandtnis zusammenhang zu
leben das ist keine art egoismus
beim menschen können sie auch
wechselseitig umbringen und das haben
sie in der geschichte immer gemacht wo
der film ende sein und trotzdem hätte
ich jetzt sozusagen das gefühl ich würde
sie nicht kennen ja trotzdem das gefühl
wenn ich jetzt die wahl hätte einer von
beiden müsste sterben ein sehr
vertrautes kaninchen oder sie einen ganz
natürlichen reflex nicht sagen
zu sagen sie sondern das kaninchen und
er ist irgendwo da der ist beim menschen
unterschiedlich aber ich kann doch jetzt
nicht als philosoph solche instinkte mal
eben so raus kürzen ja gut man kann auch
sagen psychologisch sind wie wichtig sie
erklären man kann damit erklären warum
wir uns für menschen entscheiden und ich
verdiene aber wir können das sind keine
guten gründe das könnte man ja sagen man
kann ja sozusagen direkt greift
philosophie die die psychologie nicht
ernst nimmt
ja also die rein rationalen logischen
gründen überzeugen nicht wenn sie
psychologisch nicht stimmig sind
also wenn sie contra intuitive
konsequenzen haben ja wenn das was ich
für gerecht halten dem sogenannten
gesunden menschenverstand ganz vieler
menschen widerspricht dann nützt es mir
nichts es für gerecht zu halten aber
andererseits ist auch nicht alles
richtig was die meisten menschen für
richtig und auch das stimmt auch ich das
würde ich auch sagen alle haben gegen
die geschichte der menschheit ist eine
geschichte fürchterlicher vorurteile ja
und nur weil viele menschen diese
vorurteile gehabt haben müssen sie nicht
stimmen aber wenn ich auf menschen
moralisch einwirken will muss ich sie
irgendwo da abholen wo sie stehen
das heißt nicht ich muss alles das
teilen was sie denken ich muss nicht
alles für richtig halten was sie
empfinden
aber ich kann auch keine theorie was
stellen indem das was viele menschen
denken und empfinden gar nicht
kommt mein ich sage ist es sowieso
falsch diese arroganz der philosophie
hat mir weiter gefehlt aber ich sehe die
philosophen und philosophen so ein
bisschen so dass die ideale zeichen so
sollten wir leben dahin möchten wir
kommen und das ist sozusagen das
rationale das kann man mit guten gründen
belegen und jetzt sind wir leider unser
fleisch ist schwach wir sind manchmal
nicht so gut auch wenn wir uns
anstrengen sie wir sind keine helden
aber wir haben ein ziel da müssen wir
hin vielleicht kann man jetzt sagen um
dahin zu kommen muss man auch die
gefühle der menschen darauf hinwirken
und hat sie sensibilisieren und zu
erhalten
solange ich bei meinen ideal von realen
menschen spreche ja ja und nicht wie
kant in seiner ethik ja von vulkania
also von menschen die ihre gefühle
unterdrücken können ja und die rein
rational funktionieren wenn sie nur
wollen ja also dass zum beispiel ein
unrealistisches menschenbild das einer
ethik zu grunde liegt sondern wenn ich
ein realistisches menschenbild habe dann
kann ich auf dieser basis ideale
formulieren und kann die menschen da
abholen wo sie sind aber ich kann nicht
eines bock ethik entwerfen und mich da
wundern dass sie nicht funktioniert und
sie würden sagen viele tierrechtler
haben ein falsches bild von moral und
ein falsches menschen wird ja weil
irgendwer in der tierrechtsbewegung
später sehr sehr heikle begriff und dem
augenblick wieder politisch sehr in mode
gekommene begriff der gerechtigkeit eine
große rolle und das große problem ist es
gibt keine rationalen ausweis für
gerechtigkeit
es gibt nur subjektive
gerechtigkeitsempfinden
das könnte ich einem einfachen beispiel
sagen es gibt eine bedeutende begründung
von gerechtigkeit die der liberalismus
aufgestellt hat und dass es zu sagen
gerecht ist wenn jeder die gleiche
chance kriegt ja zu sein um zu kommen
was auch immer am ende dabei rauskommt
oder ich nehme einen sozialistischen
gerechtigkeits begriff der sagt gerecht
ist wenn jeder von kuchen das gleiche
stück abkriegt was von beiden stimmt
dann wird man sofort sagen alle
gesellschaften die wir schätzen
versuchen zwischen beiden idealen
irgendwo einen ausgleich zu finden das
ist in der schweizer und das ist in
deutschland so aber auf diesem langen
weg gibt es lauter unterschiedliche
gerechtigkeitsempfinden die einen sehen
dass tendenziell eher so und die anderen
sehen dass tendenziell eher so
die gerechtigkeit hilft uns in der
moralischen diskussion in wahlkämpfen
aber nicht in der fundierung von etwas
sondern der der fortschritt der menschen
hängt nicht von ihren
gerechtigkeitsvorstellungen in erster
linie ab sondern in erster linie hängt
davon ab wie sehr ich mich für ein thema
sensibilisieren
die leute die den film gerade gesehen
haben die haben nicht gedacht das ist
nicht gerecht was wir mit den tieren
machen die haben empfunden
das können wir doch nicht tun und das
ist eigentlich der ausgangspunkt von
moral
außer der metzgermeister der
metzgermeister sieht das natürlich
anders ist auch völlig klar ich glaube
wenn sie selber jetzt schweine
schlachten müssen das erste schwein wird
die in sehr schwer fallen das
einmillionste nicht mehr so sehr
aber dann müssten sie auch nicht dieses
buch schreiben sondern filme drehen
geschichten schreiben usw um irgendwie
an die gefühle der leute heranzukommen
ich hoffe ja immer dass man
philosophische bücher auch so schrank an
dass man die menschen gefühlsmäßig
beeinflussen kann oder auf ihre gefühle
einwirken kann das ist jedenfalls das
warum ich versuche die bücher so zu
schreiben dass sie nicht nur für ein
akademisches fachpublikum lesbar sind
er hat diese diese idee ist pragmatisch
idee die sich auch bei richard rorty
findet dem leopard matt ist ein
amerikanischer philosoph das sage ich
moralische fortschritt mit
sensibilisierung zusammen geht und das
sozusagen unser mitgefühl
immer weiter geht es sind es sozusagen
unsere nahen verwandten dann sind alle
menschen als vielleicht auch die tiere
dann auch also der der kern von robbies
aussage ist das wie er sich ausdrückt
wir nicht an einem moralischen
gerichtshof appellieren sollten sondern
dass wir bei den menschen selber
anfangen sollen die wir gewinnen wollen
für unsere ideen und wo ziehen wir dann
habe ich die grenze bei den tieren also
die grenze ist und ciba ich könnte ja
sagen also und damit wird und
wahrscheinlich auch viele zuschauer
würden das ja genau so sehen also wir
sollten mit schimpansen keine
laborversuche machen und dann kriegen
wir eine ganz große einigkeit macht ja
auch fast keiner mehr in der welt jetzt
geht es um die nächste frage sollten wir
das mit makaken mit rhesusaffen machen
da sagen wir würden die leute sagen naja
wenn es um ganz ganz lebenswichtige
medikamente geht wenn es jetzt in der
aids forschung oder in der
krebsforschung ist dann oder
wenn es darum geht parkinson zu besiegen
oder als einmal dann vielleicht und das
sind einfach empfindungen gefühl das
sind empfindungen
ich kann jetzt nicht mit holzhacker
rischer sicherheit eine grenze ziehen
und sagen okay menschenaffen haben jetzt
grundsätzlich ein unantastbares recht
auf leben und rhesusaffen habe 1 70 bis
80 prozent und anpassbares und kaninchen
1 zu 40 prozent also man kann da keine
klaren grenzen ziehen das ganze ist sehr
sehr weich in der grenzziehung nur eines
ist klar die grenze die wir bisher
ziehen dass menschen tier als einen
gesonderten planeten von allen anderen
tieren zu unterscheiden diese grenze ist
biologisch unsinnig und sie ist auch
philosophisch und sehe ich ja weil das
tierschutzgesetz fast den schimpansen
und den maulwurf unter die formulierung
tiere und der menschen hält es außen vor
jetzt kann man ja sagen genetisch sind
menschen und schimpansen ungefähr ein
prozent ihres erbmaterials voneinander
unterschieden und schimpansen und
maulwürfe sind nicht jahre voneinander
entfernt also diese grenze mensch tiere
wie wir die machen ist falsch
ohne dass ich jetzt in der lage wäre zu
sagen es ist ganz klar wo die grenze
ziehen muss ja nämlich zwischen den
johannitern als dem dritten großen
menschenaffen und dem vierten und dem
geboren als kleinen menschenaffen oder
zwischen dem geboren und in paris also
wir kommen nie zu einer sicheren grenze
aber ich behaupte ja dass wir sie auch
nicht brauchen
sie haben kein kriterium und zu
entscheiden ist meine politische dinge
gibt einen sagen er sagt
empfindungsfähigkeit und dann hat er
noch so etwas wie zukunfts bewusst sein
selbstbewusstsein für höher entwickelte
säugetiere um dann zu sagen selbst die
dürfen nicht nicht schmerzlos töten so
wir haben menschen einfach geschwänzt
wird und tim regan ein anderer zu
erraten das gegengewicht wurde der
sozusagen grundrechte fordert für die
tiere eben dass ein tötungsversuch der
sagte auch letztlich
empfindungsfähigkeit das ist aber für
sie also gering ist ja noch ein bisschen
anders also also regen kommt ja aus der
kantischen tradition und da geht es um
die lebenswert und erlebenswert jedes
mit bewusstsein versehen lebewesen das
sich als subjekt eines lebens begreift
das ist
also präferenzen hat absicht neigungen
sind ängste hoffnung
jedes wir sind das darüber verfügt hat
ein unbedingtes ein unbedingtes das sagt
nämlich singer nicht ein unbedingtes
lebensrecht dass man nicht auf wie
dieser gedanke stampfen kann und zwar
bezogen auf den mensch und zu sagen also
drei menschen haben nicht mehr
lebensrecht als einer weil der mensch
ist an sich bereits das höchste was es
überhaupt gibt und also oder die
formulierung bekannt heißt der mensch
sein zweck an sich
er darf nicht verzehrt werden und
deswegen besitzt er die menschenwürde
und diese menschenwürde möchte ich jetzt
regen aus denen auf alle anderen tiere
die genau wie der mensch nicht genauso
aber philosophisch gesehen sozusagen im
selben schema ihr habt präferenzen haben
uns objekt eines lebens sind
und das bedeutet natürlich in der
konsequenz dass das lebensrecht eines
kaninchens das objekt eines lebens ist
genau das gleiche ist wie mainz und iris
und da würde ich schon wieder sagen
contra intuitive konsequenzen ja meinen
sie das ernst wenn es jetzt darum geht
ein serum zu testen
und ich sage ich brauche ein einziges
kaninchen an dem ich es essen kann und
ich kann eine million menschen retten
ist natürlich wie alle philosophischen
beispiele haaren herbeigezogen aber nur
um das prinzip klar zu einer wird 99,9
prozent der menschen sagen teste dass
dort menschen die sich an wo ein
kaninchen ja dafür kannst du das meint
mein leben und das leben meiner kinder
und das leben war der verwandten und der
ganzen stadt retten müsste aber sagen ja
unbedingt das lebensrecht also müsst ihr
account sagen mit blick auf menschen ich
meine dass sarah connor schlag wie kann
hintergrund silber das sagte mikos
menschen folterverbot und so weiter auch
wenn ich jetzt 10.000 menschen retten
können ändert dürfte man nicht wahr das
ist auch grundrente stimmt also liegt es
nicht an der tierethik sondern einfach
sozusagen account es liegt dann erkannte
stetig ja das liegt anerkannten ethik
die grundsätzlich diese ganzen
intuitionen aus der ethik aus kürzt das
macht sie so ehrenwert ja aber es macht
sie gleichzeitig so unmenschlich
also kann es grandios aber sie ist nicht
für menschen
mich interessiert was wenn sie sagen
contra intuitive konsequenz ich meine
früher hat man auch gedacht ist klar
vonn holt uns nochmals der welt contra
intuitiv an dieselben rechte hätten wir
reichen weißen oder frauen ich meine
intuition verändert sich ja und schon
kann sie doch auch sensibilisierung ist
das ein absolut aber gute argumente
lasst doch mal genau so wichtig gute
argumente helfen zwar sensibilisierung
talker ja ganz klar natürlich
also es gibt einen gewaltigen
fortschritt ich haben heute in der
unserer westlichen welt ein völlig
anderes verhältnis zu frauen als die
alten griechen das an und wir haben ein
völlig anderes verhältnis zur sklaverei
ich meine auch wir leben in unserer
westlichen welt unsere werte nicht so
ganz ernst ja aber wir nehmen sie sehr
weitgehend ernst nicht so ganz ernst
bedeutet das wenn sehr viele flüchtlinge
in die schweiz freuen wie er plötzlich
den menschenrechten etwas abstand nehmen
und sagen ja die haben jetzt aber nicht
die gleichen möglichkeiten sollen die
gleichen möglichkeiten kriegen ihr
lebensglück zu verwirklichen und so
weiter weil wir können auch nicht jeden
aufnehmen
das heißt noch mal zehn prozent abstrich
vom wohlstand würde bereits bedeuten die
menschenrechte von ländern von menschen
aus anderen ländern kommen nicht mehr so
ernst zu nehmen das ist tatsächlich so
nah und sehr viele textilien diese in
der schweiz kaufen können wird von
kinderarbeit in bangladesch hergestellt
oder der cacau kommt sklavenarbeit von
kindern in ghana und so weiter ja und
das alles wissen wir irgendwo aber
wollen wir nicht so genau ist ähnlich
wie geschafft obwohl wir uns jederzeit
zu den menschenrechten beginnen leute
wie tom reagan oder gary fraktion die
fordern ja auch eine abschaffung
sozusagen dieser sklaverei wie sie das
nennen von tieren ist ein napoli
zionismus
aber das heißt auch so zum beispiel oder
tierversuche müsste man abschaffen
wie stehen sie dazu zumal also dazu ich
würde sowas nicht abschaffen
ich würde ich habe ein intensives
verhältnis zu ziehen es ist natürlich so
dass es keinen zugibt in dem es nicht
verhältnisse gibt die ich abschaffen
würde ja ehrlich gesagt gehe ich damit
aber überein mit den meisten
zoodirektoren also es ist ja auch nicht
so dass ein so direkt bei jeder anlage
die in seinem zoo ist gut findet und
nicht jeder so hat solche gewaltigen
möglichkeiten finanziell wie der zoo in
zürich der nun tatsächlich in der lage
ist den ganzen vogel zu bauen und so was
wie das regenwaldhaus für die linke
zu bauen das zu einem der besten so
gebäude der welt gehört so und wenn ich
da die lemuren rollen und bällen höhere
und jetzt überhaupt erst mal lange
suchen muss gesicht überhaupt finde dann
habe ich jetzt nicht das gefühl dass das
eigentum das kann man sagen dass
freiheitsberaubung
da würde ich aber sofort sagen also das
was wir unter freiheit verstehen ist
noch nicht mal etwas was der mensch
unter freiheit versteht sondern es ist
etwas was wir im jahre 2017 in ländern
wie der schweiz oder in ländern wie
deutschland unter freiheit verstehen das
ist schon völlig was anderes als das was
der alte grieche unter freiheit
verstanden hat und das ist was anderes
als dass in der unter freiheit verstehen
und jetzt projizieren wir unsere
freiheits vorstellungen die wir im jahre
2017 haben in die lemuren rein und sagen
man darf die nicht halten das ist
natürlich ein extremer anthropozän
tourismus das heißt nicht umgekehrt dass
wenn ich sehe dass dieses tier seine
natürlichen verhaltensweisen nicht
ausleben kann in einem kleinen käfig und
so weiter das ist nicht in ordnung ist
völlig klar
aber ich muss auch ein unterschied
machen es muss immer versuchen sozusagen
nach besten wissen und gewissen zu
versuchen zu verstehen was in diesem
tier vor sich geht soweit das überhaupt
möglich ist
und angesichts davon muss ich überlegen
was könnte eine artgerechte haltung von
tieren sein
was passiert denn wenn die zoos völlig
aus der lebenswelt verschwinden alles
was sozusagen aus dem nachwuchs von der
menschen verschwindet verliert auch
meistens seinen belangen
was ich nicht sehen oder anfassen kann
der kinder werden damit sozialisiert
tiger oder was tolles sind wenn sie die
im zu sehen und wenn das alles weg ist
wenn das nur noch im fernsehen ist
können sie auch computeranimationen sein
also fonds könnte rein theoretisch eine
gute funktion erfüllen ja noch mal es
gibt ganz viele infos was mir nicht
gefällt
aber ich wünsche mir als
anthropologische begegnungsstätten als
orte der kontemplation als orte in dem
das menschen tier seinen artgenossen
begegnet unter den für sie bestmöglichen
umständen und auf diese art und weise
sich sozusagen das gewand des
zusammenhanges in dem menschen und tiere
in der natur miteinander verbunden sind
wieder bewusst wird und dafür müssen sie
sich natürlich gegenüber jetztigen zu
verändern
aber sie könnten eine wichtige funktion
und 10 und 10 katrin schimpansen
orang-utans gorillas ja also ich glaube
ich unbedingt
also ich persönlich bin kein großer
freund der menschenaffen haltung ist hat
sich viel getan
also die beste anlage im augenblick ist
in leipzig die muss man sich angucken
wenn man darüber redet und da muss man
muss man abstimmung machen was für
gefühle man hat wenn man das eher
leipzig sieht also wo die auch nicht auf
den kacheln leben sondern wurde als
untergrund haben riesige freianlagen wo
man die tiere gar nicht sieht ich bin
bei menschenaffen nicht so sicher also
ich als zoodirektor wäre ich jetzt nicht
so froh darüber
menschenaffen zu halten und zu begründen
das damit dass viele menschen affen in
der natur nicht überleben werden orang
utans mit sicherheit nicht trotz alledem
was dafür getan wird also der gegendruck
beim öl industrie und das abfackeln des
regenwaldes sind so gewaltig nur ist die
frage wenn man sie nicht mehr in
indonesien halten kann muss man sie dann
in zürich halten
oder gibt es nicht andere möglichkeiten
wo man sie halten kann unter anderen
bedingungen aber menschen es gab schon
mal zeiten darum menschen menschen im
zoo ausgestellt ja mit menschen mögen
wir das heute niemals machen ja warum
sollte das warum denken wir überhaupt
darüber nach ob das erlaubt sein soll
oder nicht
mit sympathien mit menschenaffen
auszumachen ja also ich kann ihre
meinung teilen ich sehe den
menschenaffen haltungen zu als
problematisch an
wir denken natürlich darüber nach weil
wir sagen das sind keine menschen
gleichzeitig aber ist die zentrale
erfahrung wenn man mal was anderes macht
als noch mal ganz kurz zu gucken und
guck mal dass ein gorilla und gegen die
scheibe zu klopfen sondern dem mal zwei
stunden beobachtet dann hat man
plötzlich das gefühl dass der
unterschied doch sehr sehr sehr klein
wird und je kleiner dieser unterschied
wird umso seltsamer muss einem vorkommen
dass der hinter der falschen gitter
seite sitzt
und das kann ich sehr gut verstehen also
ich verstehe jeden der menschenaffen
haltung und so ablehnt also das argument
das sind keine menschen das ist erst mal
gar kein argument man ja also das ist
immer das problem wir haben ihn erinnert
ihre ethik und das problem hatten regen
und singer natürlich auch wir gucken
natürlich doch immer ein bisschen neben
leiden und interessen auf menschen
ähnlichkeit wir denken immer der mensch
das soziales leidensfähige wesen weil
das komplexeste bewusstsein hat wir
können uns ja selbst fertigen fürchten
die es nicht gibt ja unsere fantasien
können in alle richtungen wuchern
natürlich sind wir unglaublich sensibel
und leidensfähig und lange hat man auch
der glaubt spinosa hat das noch geglaubt
der mensch verfügen über biologisch den
komplexen organismus und es ist
natürlich interessant zu sehen dass es
andere lebewesen gibt nun ganz anderen
ast der evolution sich entwickelt haben
wie zum beispiel die ziffern boden
kopffüßler und die kraken zu gehören die
kalmare dass die ein unglaublich
komplexen biologischen organismus haben
und so weit wir das ablesen können also
die idee in hunderten von farbnuancen
schattierung miteinander kommunizieren
können
ihr halbes leben in liebesspiel
miteinander verbringen drei klitoris
drei penisse lebewesen die über drei
herzen verfügen über neun gehirne das
ist natürlich unglaublich komplexe
lebewesen sind und da würde ich sagen
jetzt gehen nicht nur von menschen aus
also kranken möchte ich in keinem
meerwasseraquarium gehalten sehen und
schon gar nicht essen
wie ist es eine krake zu sagen können
wir das überhaupt wissen wir werden das
nie wissen also es gibt ja diesen
berühmten aufsatz sehen sie auch kennen
von thomas niggl
der eben gleichen jahr übrigens wieder
single buch also 1975 erschienen ist die
ist das eine fledermaus zu sein und das
ergebnis ist dass wir niemals wissen
können wie es ist eine fledermaus zu
sein weil wir natürlich schon ganz
schwer uns irgendwie noch vorstellen
können wie das wäre wenn wir mit
verbundenen augen im zickzack mit einer
echolot ortung durch eine höhle fliegen
also das ist schon schwer genug sich das
russische aber alles was wir dann am
ende wissen jetzt wie es sich für uns
ein fühlt
wir wissen aber deswegen nicht wie es
sich für die fledermaus anführt
also am ende ist uns anderes bewusstsein
nicht zugänglich wer ist ja noch nicht
mal ihr bewusstsein tatsächlich
zugänglich kann ja nur aufgrund von
indizien beobachtungen ungefähres bild
davon machen deswegen plädieren sie auch
für eine ethik des nichtwissens ja dass
es sozusagen gegen all diejenigen die
sagen also das gehört jetzt in die ethik
rein ja sagen wir mal alle wirbeltiere
und so ist das bei regen der sich auch
nicht ganz sicher beim fischen und so
aber sagen also ok säugetiere gehören da
rein vögel gehören da rein und tische
vielleicht und dann machen wir die
grenze geht natürlich schon wegen der
kranken nicht
ich würde also sofort die kraken darüber
holen ja und würde den den maulwurf
ziemlich weit auf die andere seite
schieben mit einem vergleichsweise wenig
komplexer bewusstsein und weil wir da
nie sichere grenzen haben würde ich
immer sagen nach bestem wissen und
gewissen
angesichts der tatsache dass wir
tatsächlich gar nicht so viel wissen
können also im zweifelsfall für das tier
man merkt schon sie wissen unglaublich
viel über tiere und sie ist so etwas wie
ihr lebensthema auch sie wollten früher
auch selbst so direktor werden haben zu
hause ein großes aquarium was fasziniert
sie an tieren
ja ich gehöre zu den menschen die so von
hunden und katzen und kaninchen jetzt
nicht so fasziniert sind sondern in
erster linie fasziniert sind von
lebewesen die ganz anders sind als
menschen
also es ist die andersartigkeit ich bin
ich staune über die millionen wege die
die evolution gefunden hat komplexe
lebewesen hervorzubringen über über die
verrücktesten mechanismen so beschreiben
es die biologen und ich würde sagen die
befremdlichen aber statt erstaunlichsten
bewusstseinszustände die diese tiere und
diese lebewesen wir haben müssen wir
neigen ja dazu durch diese wohl der
darwinistische perspektive ja das gehirn
der tiere zu reduzieren auf
wo kriege ich einen sexualpartner hier
schlagig nebenbuhler in die flucht und
wirklich genug zu essen
und wer wird das gleiche beim menschen
machen würden würde sagen sehr
reduktionistischen menschen dieses
reduktionistischen bild das haben wir
überall in der natur jeder naturfilm
erklärt ihnen der löwe macht das umzug
ja alles ist nur um zu ein biologischer
mechanismus und alles ist um zu alles in
runder maschinen überlebens maschinen
und da ich menschen nicht so betrachte
bin ich auch ganz ganz ganz vorsichtig
andere lebewesen jetzt einfach so
reduktionistischen nur einzig und allein
darauf zu reduzieren und sagen wenn ich
regenzeit kommt und dass genug übt ja
und das machen die sie vor freude
luftsprünge usw
was hat das für zweck das ist auch
nichts anderes als eine
insulinausschüttung dass es regnet das
ist doch nicht um zu weil wir wissen
aber jetzt entsteht ein wasserloch die
fertigkeit sondern das ist einfach
freude ja und hier kürze das heißt jeder
den hund hat ja dass sie dass dieses
tier etwas mehr ist als nur eine
überlebens maschine aber das ist
sozusagen der biologische blick den wir
uns angewöhnt haben wenn wir über die
natur sprechen und ich kann die
ästhetische faszination von mir fremden
bewusstsein ja sehr stark empfinden
einig in der natur bin und das ist das
was mich an tieren fasziniert dass es
noch werte gibt die nicht der mensch
geschaffen hat die auch so da sind aber
erst recht wenn sie sagen im zweifel für
das tier dann müssten sie doch
eigentlich veganer sein das heißt auf
tierische produkte insgesamt verzichten
wir wissen ja nicht genau wie sich das
anfühlt einzelzellen eingekerkert gut
muscheln kann man nicht im monat die
grenze ziehen aber zum militärrichter
also die es gibt eine
tierrechtsorganisation haye argumentiert
hat ich habe gesagt muscheln hätte ich
jetzt kein problem zu essen und die mir
versucht haben zu erklären dass auch
muscheln ja einen lebens interesse haben
also dann wenn man diesen gedanken
radikal spinnt dann wird es natürlich
insofern sehr ernst weil bei pflanzen
bin ich mir bei dem lebens interesse
auch nicht so ganz ganz sicher
also es gibt ja sehr erstaunliche
entwicklung im mittlerweile beim studium
von pflanzen ist die bewusstsein hat ja
nicht dass ihr bewusstsein haben dass du
dich
der muschel auch nicht an aber lebens
interesse okay nicht bewusst des lebens
interesse was ja bei den muscheln
ausreicht damit der veganer wenig ist
und da frage ich mich wenn das ausreicht
ja dann liegt die grenze nicht bei der
muschel
dann könnt ihr die auch schon bei den
pilzen sein oder banken den pflanzen die
ihren weg zum licht suchen oder aber
insekten fangen in den pflanzen und so
aber nochmal wäre es nicht konsequent
wenn sie welche handeln leben würden ja
sie haben gerade gesagt ob es eigentlich
konsequent und ich würde sagen
eigentlich ist es konsequent aber ich
bin nicht konsequent ich bin ich
konsequent in moral am ende auch nicht
darauf ankommt dass wir in allen
moralischen fragen unausgesetzt
konsequenz sind
das kann nicht das ziel sein also am
ende müsste dann das ziel der ethik
darin bestehen dass er ein heiliger wird
ich akzeptiere das finde das wunderbar
wenn jemand veganer ist aber ich kann
den maßstab dass es im leben darauf
ankommt ein durch und durch guter mensch
zu sein dann kann ich nicht teilen
also wenn man versucht ein besserer
mensch zu werden ist das schon ziemlich
viel also der einer der klügsten
menschen die über die ethik nachgedacht
haben ist ein schweizer jean claude wolf
und jean-claude wolf vertritt eine
medizinische ethik und zwar eine ethik
von gut besser am besten und nicht eine
von schwarz und weiß also nicht entweder
ich bin veganer ja oder ich bin schlecht
sondern jeder soll sich im rahmen seiner
möglichkeiten sensibilisieren und
überlegen wie weit er sozusagen auf
diesem pfad zum guten hin sich
orientiert und es ist immer noch besser
jemand ist nur öko produkte oder bio
fleisch aus bio landwirtschaft als er
ist massentierhaltung fleisch und ist
noch besser verzichtet darauf und es ist
noch besser er wird wegen aber ich kann
nicht mit dem eisernen maßstab alle
sollen jetzt veganer werden eine ethik
für heilige in dieser gesellschaft
versuchen zu etablieren ist es nie
gelingen wieder zu dem thema menschen
dort abholen wo sie sind
sie sagen ja in zehn gleich 20 jahren
gibt es keine schlachthöfe mehr
oder wir brauchen sie nicht mehr warum
es gibt mehrere gründe also dass die art
und weise wir haben darüber gesprochen
der massentierhaltung wie sie
gegenwärtig funktioniert läuft
ökonomisch irgendwo leer also das system
dreht hohl wenn ich immer größere
agrarfabriken bauen muss um auf dem
weltmarkt überhaupt noch standhalten zu
können
also wir verabschieden uns links aus der
erde passieren landwirtschaft genannt
haben und bauen immer riesige
agrarfabriken in dem das ganze natürlich
eine immer seelenlose angelegenheit wird
und das ist wird von der mehrheit der
bevölkerung weder in der schweiz noch in
deutschland akzeptiert und wenn wir das
nicht so sehr im verborgenen betreiben
würden wären die proteste wenn das erst
in innenstädten machen würden wenn die
proteste noch sehr viel lauter also das
kriegt einen immer größeren widerstand
denn jetzt aber nicht der hauptgrund ist
ja schön wenn es ein rein moralischer
fortschritt wird aber offensichtlich
wird das ende der massentierhaltung
eingeläutet durch technische
möglichkeiten
das eine ist man das heute in der lage
produkte herzustellen die absolut wir
fleisch schmecken aber kein sind das ist
ein gewaltiger wachstumsmarkt even
alternative und da wird sehr viel geld
investiert und wir machen große
fortschritte und das wird mehr werden
und mehr werden da gibt es firmen die
jetzt schon gewaltige marktanteile
bekommen hat die früher nur fleisch
gemacht haben und die jetzt mit dem der
alternative zu fleisch viel geld
verdienen und das andere ist vor vier
jahren hat eine universität maastricht
ein wissenschaftler namens mark post
eine print einen nackten zelle entnommen
als diese zelle in einer petrischale
vermehrt und hat daraus einen burger
hergestellt so und für diesen bürger
musste tatsächlich noch tiere sterben
und zwar deswegen weil man das kälber
sie rum benutzt um die zellen zu
vermehren als nährlösung das wird man
wahrscheinlich irgendwann nicht mehr
brauchen da findet man auch was wo kein
team mehr versterben musste so und jetzt
haben wir echtes fleisch das sich nur
nicht im tier geteilt hat ja sondern der
petrischale
aber im prinzip das gleiche also das
produkt ist ein rein tierschutz produkt
und dafür müssen irgendwann keine tiere
mehr sterben dafür brauchen wir keine
anbauflächen mehr
dafür muss kein regenwald gerodet werden
dafür können wir 80 prozent des
gegenwärtigen wassers was wir in der
tierhaltung haben einsparen
das ist das ende jenes ökologischen
schreckensszenario uns was wir vorher
gemacht haben jetzt können sie natürlich
persönlich nur sagen das würde ich nicht
essen das finde ich gesundheit nicht
komisch der gentechnik gentechnik
andererseits glaube ich dass menschen
sich an sogenannte künstliche produkte
schnell gewöhnen also bier wächst auch
nirgendwo ist auch in china
hergestelltes produkt und ich glaube das
wird man sehr schnell merken wird dass
diese produkte wenn die auf den markt
kommen gesundheitlich besser sind als
jenes form aus von massentierhaltung
fleisch das voller hormone ist
wachstumshormone
wo ist radio de drin sind im kalbfleisch
und und und ya antibiotika rückstände
also das wird erst dann auf den markt
kommen wenn es deutlich gesünder ist und
es wird irgendwann sehr viel günstiger
werden das ist jetzt sehr teuer ganz
klar dass in der experimentierphase
aber irgendwann wird das sehr sehr viel
günstiger sein dass wir fast nichts mehr
kosten im vergleich zu wir können nicht
in fleisch und spätestens dann ist die
massentierhaltung tot dann werden zum
teil die gleichen leute die jetzt ihr
geld wenn massentierhaltung verdienen
darin investieren es gibt jetzt schon
große investoren im silicon valley dass
die java das ist natürlich ein
zweischneidiges schwert weil es ist das
silicon valley ist ganz aktiv darin ja
also darin dass er drin von google und
peter thiel facebook paypal ist auch da
drin und die große gefahr die jetzt
besteht ist wenn wir sagen was finden
wir nicht gut ja das finden wir so wir
mögen keine gentechnik da haben wir was
gegen das ist alles künstlich und so
bringen wir bestimmt wir alle gehen von
und so dann werden dass diese großen
firmen machen und die wären solche
monopole aufbauen wie google und
facebook das in der digitalen welt sind
und dann werden sie sich ihr verfahren
patentieren lassen
ja und dann kommt kein anderer mehr in
den markt rein wenn wir nicht jetzt
begreifen so wie man den siebzigern
hätte begreifen müssen rechtzeitig in
die erneuerbaren energien zu gehen dass
das das große zukunftsmodell ist dann
werden wir dieser entwicklung hinterher
und das spannende ist ich habe jetzt
drei diskussionen gehabt da saßen wir
klassische öko bauern gegenüber
die haben mich völlig angegiftet als ich
das erzählt habe was für ein schmutziger
trick da versucht man die leute über
lange zeit dazu zu bringen
moralischer zu essen und jetzt kommt
plötzlich eine technische lösung nicht
anstrengend naja und damit wird und auch
noch gentechnik und ich selber habe
ganz ganz viel geschrieben gegen die
sogenannte grüne gentechnik gegen die
monopolbildung die damit einhergehende
umweltrisiken usw
ich bin kein freund der gentechnik als
gentechnik aber wenn ich doch erkenne
dass ich hier mit
eines der größten probleme der
menschheit tatsächlich lösen kann
und wenn ich mir dann rechtzeitig
gedanken darüber machen wie sieht das
ökonomische modell an
aus wer profitiert davon ja wer baut
diese silos in denen die zellkulturen
vermehrt werden wenn ich mir also jetzt
nicht hinterherhinken sondern vornherein
diese gedanken mache dann kann ich damit
was aufbauen
das muss hier müssen sie ja nicht erst
muss ich ja auch nicht zwingend essen
ich kann ja auch lieber vegetarier
werden verspricht ja gar nicht sehen
aber wir hatten vorhin von den 200
millionen chinesen geredet die wollen
nicht alle vegetarier werden sind froh
dass sie keine mehr sind und für die ist
das die lösung
diese lösung haben wir hier wie sieht
dann ungefähr so aus in der petrischale
fleisch gezüchtet ja das hier ist leider
noch echtes fleisch eine tochter dafür
müsst ihr sterben sowie das ungefähr
aussehen dass da jetzt auch eine lösung
das wäre eine alternative dazu
das sind mädels ja und grillen ja
unglaublich protein reißt jedoch
vielfach angepriesen china haben sie
erwähnt und damit ist man auch für
solche sachen
wir werden uns ja ja es schmeckt so wie
es hier aussieht ein bisschen langweilig
aber wenn ich das jetzt an ihre und mit
erdnussbutter es sieht das ja schon
gleich also deutlich besser aus wie
ungesalzene schütz wir wollten sich
überhaupt nichts da schmeckt noch gar
nichts dort könnte ihm lassen essen und
auch kein dschungelcamp die regeln auf
sondern man stellt sich wirklich eklig
gerade davor erst mal was sagt das
gefühl ich esse ungesalzene schmecken ja
auch nichts wenn ich das ganz sicher
zeit mit paprika kann ihre wie könnte
ich das sozusagen zum länderspiel als
chips essen würden wir nicht groß
auffallend ist am erstmal ein bisschen
komisch wenn die gäste kommen denkt man
müsse ein bisschen seltsam aber
irgendwann konnten hat viele leute
machen wie gedacht man kann das ja ein
bisschen dekorativer machen dann muss ja
nicht nur in reinform kenia oder redet
oder sowas
war das das erste mal dass das gegessen
aber ich habe oft erzählen lassen wie es
schmeckt und da ich ja in diesem leben
sehr wahrscheinlich nie an einem
dschungel camp teilnehmen werde habe ich
mich allerdings wenn ich das schon mal
gesehen habe auch gefragt also eklig ist
das wenn sie im nächsten leben ein tier
sein könnten
selbst der frage welches es gebe zwei
das ist eben gerade der der krake also
sein halbes leben mit liebesspiele so zu
bringen ist natürlich eine faszinierende
vorstellung nachteil des kranken ist er
wird nicht alt also unsere mittelmeer
kranken werden maximal zweieinhalb jahre
alt und die großen pazifischen
riesenkraken vielleicht 5 außer die
haben ein anderes zeit bewusst sein kann
natürlich mit rousseau sagen ja nicht
derjenige hat am meisten gelebt die am
ältesten wird sondern der meisten
gefühlt hat also es kann ja sein dass
sich zweieinhalb jahre eines kranken
lebens so unglaublich erfüllt anfühlen
das was schöner ist als 80 jahre
menschenleben und das zweite tier ist
mein absolutes lieblings dir deswegen
ich mal für längere zeit auf den
philippinen war das ist der so genannte
philippinen adler früher ist der
affenart war und dass es eines der
faszinierendsten lebewesen so eine art
lebender wie der aktor also ist einer
der grössten adler der welt und er hat
so eine haube die man so aufstellen kann
das ist ein adler mit grau blauen augen
und danach papa dahin schnabel der also
sehr viel auf den ästen umherläuft und
dann unglaublich schönes tier ist das
ist das schönste was ich kenne und
fliegen zu können es ist etwas da habe
ich auch im 60 kind davon geträumt
und da ich viel zu viel angst hatte
bisher segelfliegen oder ähnliches zu
machen wäre die schönste art und weise
mich in einen philippinen adler zu
transformieren erbrecht vielen
herzlichen dank für dieses gespräch
gerne
mit dem thema fleisch essen beschäftigen
sich derzeit auch unsere kollegen von
einsteigen
in ihrer nächsten sendung präsentieren
sie nämlich die erste ernährungs
erhebung der schweiz auf diese zahlen
darf man gespannt sein
kommenden donnerstag um 21 uhr ein stein
auf sf1 und nächsten sonntag setzten wir
uns das hier auf ein pussy hat barbara
bleisch spricht mit lori penny einer der
derzeit wichtigsten und frechsten
feministinnen über den alltäglichen
sexismus und darüber dass die nächste
revolution feministisch sein wird nun
wünsche ich ihnen einen schönen sonntag
[Musik]